Seaside duels heartbroken mother's
vengeful thugs as 1923's first season
comes to a close the growing Dutton
family sits more precariously than ever
if fans of Taylor Sheridan's work
haven't noticed by now one of the
prevailing themes is the importance of
family from his early features like hell
or high water to Sylvester Stallone's
crime comedy Tulsa King Sheridan's
stories have almost all revolved around
the power and pull of family nowhere is
this truer than in Yellowstone and its
spin-off 1923. this theme runs most
obviously through the story of Jacob
Dutton and his clan and how there is
nothing more that motivates the staunch
patriarch than his love of his kin he
does everything for them and them alone
the finale makes clear that families
come in all manner of shapes and sizes
and it doesn't matter what shape it may
be family is all that matters tragically
Injustice abounds in 1923 as much as it
does in the real world when the law
comes to arrest Rancher Zane Davis's
wife for the crime of marrying a white
man at the same time Jacob's family is
falling apart with his new niece
miscarrying a pregnancy aimed the family
home on the verge of being taken by
Donald Whitfield the word decent doesn't
apply to me
while freedom to live work and love are
generally held as fundamental human
rights 1923 takes a hard look at the
many ways these needs are denied to
large populations of people by the end
of season 1 many of the characters can
see that freedom is not always
guaranteed on the reservation tiona's
Fight For Freedom forces her to kill
pushing back against the oppression she
faces after being taken from her family
and forced into a Catholic boarding
school in their attempt to take away her
identity through cruelty and torture
they inadvertently unleash her Inner
Warrior now if she wants to live free
she must fight harder than ever before
luckily she stands alongside her
Rescuers her father and Pete plenty
clouds as they look to start a new life
together while on the run from America's
lawmen the duttons meanwhile face their
own Fight For Freedom as a new day in
America Dawns and more and more laws
begin to strip them of their sovereignty
Jacob Dutton is forced to Fight Fire
with Fire that may mean a fight in the
fields with guns and guts or it might
mean a battle in the boardroom facing
off against ruthless businessmen who
would use guile and cunning to take from
him everything that he's built
not long after the events of 1883 the
wild west is already fading as Pioneers
begin building up the west and the law
starts to make its way to the frontier
by the era of 1923 however the Mountains
of Montana are firmly becoming part of
the modern world though they are still
well behind the big cities like New York
and San Francisco we've seen through the
course of the Season that automobiles
are slowly taking over for horses and
electricity is finally finding its way
into homes Jacob Dutton has been
resistant to such change though his wife
Cara seems happy to have a washing
machine to make her household chores
easier in the finale we see the truest
extent of modern changes as horse
hitchers in the city have been removed
from the street to make way for
automobile parking spaces and new 20th
century laws allow bankers and tycoons
to take away a person's house and home
through Shady business deals Jacob
Dutton a man born before the Civil War
is a remnant of an old world where
problems were solved with a fist or a
gun and somewhat paradoxically neighbors
respected each other's livelihoods and
cared for their Community likewise
tiona's people who once roamed free and
loved the land now have modern American
laws dictating their way of life change
is inevitable and if 1923 tells us
anything it's that while change can be
good it can also cause harm when
controlled by the wrong people I have
compassion but
I have no mercy
while on the run from the law throughout
the later portion of season one tiona
has been forced to kill several of her
pursuers before she gets discovered by
her father with a U.S Marshal on their
tail they're forced to flee to Wyoming
where they hope to join a new clan of
Comanche down south and begin a new
chapter of their lives however with so
much turmoil in her Young Life tiona
defies her father and begins a romance
with Pete plenty clouds partially due to
the fact that her experiences this
season have taught her that tomorrow
isn't guaranteed these lessons have also
been learned by The duttons Who are
ready to take matters into their own
hands rather than to wait out the return
of their intended savior Spencer with
Donald Whitfield at their door ready to
take the land beneath their feet and
steal the Yellowstone Ranch and banner
Creighton ready to see them all dead in
a hail of gunfire waiting is not an
option for all of our protagonists
prosperity and survival depend on taking
action immediately because there may not
be a later this is a wisdom that Spencer
and Alexandra learned earlier this
season like tiona and Pete they jump
headfirst into a romance because the
dangers of Life allow no room for
patience they were right not to waste
the time as they've been forced apart by
Fate by the end of the season
in the season finale Spencer and
Alexandra finally set sail for American
Shores but they are forced to deal with
a new problem this time though it's not
the harsh sting of nature that
interferes with their love but the spite
of a spurned lover Alex's former husband
in Waiting Arthur in the finale it's
revealed that Arthur is more than just
Alex's ex-fiance but the Earl of Sussex
whose father is a prince in the line of
succession with all three forced
together during their Voyage on the RMS
Majestic ocean liner Alex is initially
determined to avoid a confrontation by
staying in her cabin for the entirety of
their trip but when frustrations with
their situation boil over Alex and
Spencer agree that the only way to deal
with their problems is head on
unfortunately this leads to a new crisis
as Arthur challenges Spencer to a duel
on the deck Spencer wins the day but is
forced to throw Arthur overboard when
the bitter ex-lover pulls a pistol
leading to the Hunter's arrest and
expulsion from the ship and a possibly
permanent separation from the woman he
loves
more than any series yet 1923 appears to
be Taylor Sheridan's way of making
crystal clear how he feels about the
rich and Powerful more than once he's
shown the villainous mining magnate
Donald Whitfield using his wealth to
attain control over others in perverse
and corrupt ways in a revealing moment
Whitfield spells out what might be the
series biggest message chatting with his
crony Banner Creighton Whitfield says
bluntly that true wealth isn't just
being rich it's being so rich that you
can't possibly spend all of your money
in your own lifetime I could never spend
all the money I've made what I do now
ensures that my great-grandchildren
can't either
to achieve this generational wealth
Whitfield proclaims that he must take
from those he deems unworthy and his
Target is the Dutton Ranch and one of
the episode's final scenes he even
admits that he feels no need to act with
honor or respect loud and clear 1923
tells us that the search for Power and
money leads to evil and that wealth
alone is not a signal of virtue nobility
or strength of character
by the conclusion of the first season of
1923 Jacob Dutton has found himself in a
world of trouble he's been surrounded by
his enemies the rich and Powerful Donald
Whitfield and the thuggish and vengeful
Banner Creighton while Jacob wants
Justice for the family members who
Banner directly and indirectly murdered
the law is making it more and more
difficult to get it however Jacob is far
from blameless as the feud begins when
he hangs Banner's men for trespassing on
his land so his sheep could graze Jacob
knows that the law isn't always about
Justice and as a man of the old west he
takes it into his own hands this
decision comes back to bite him as the
case against Banner falls apart due to
dutton's Hasty attempt at Frontier
Justice the law also isn't helping tiona
on the reservation as it's unwilling to
consider the abuse and torture she
receives at the hands of the sisters at
the Catholic boarding school likewise
Spencer's story is also marred by the
corruption of law enforcement aboard the
Majestic Arthur's Royal father uses his
position to shift the law in his favor
by having Spencer removed from the ocean
liner and and ripped from Alex's arms
after Spencer defeats his son this Ship
Sails under a British flag
and a prince in succession has already
removed from the vessel
while many believe that the future is
what they make it to be many others
believe Destiny to be pre-ordained even
if we feel like we can exercise Free
Will in the moment Nothing Left to Lose
solidifies That 1923 clearly stands in
the latter camp with its characters
under the impression Destiny is not
something they have much of a say in for
Jack and Elizabeth Destiny has dire
consequences we learn that the attack on
the ranch earlier in the season may have
permanently impaired Elizabeth's ability
to Bear children following her
miscarriage she Ponders what kind of
life she will have if she's unable to
start a family in response Jack declares
that if it's not their Destiny to be
parents then they shall find out
together what their Destiny really is he
doesn't feel that he chose Elizabeth for
his wife but that Destiny made the match
and he went along for the ride he also
wonders if perhaps their Destiny is to
raise someone else's children orphans
who need a home just as his aunt Cara
did when she and Jacob arrived in
Montana after the death of James and
Margaret Dutton left their children
alone
as Yellowstone has demonstrated for
years a central theme in the
dutton-shared universe is that of a
found family in the parent series we've
seen this play out more than once with
son Jaime discovered to have been
adopted by John Dutton as a baby later
he brought a wayward rip wheeler into
the fold if not as family than as the
next best thing dutton's daughter Beth
along with her husband rip later
fostered Young Carter an orphan without
a home proving that family is built off
of far more than blood in 1923 we
learned that it was Jacob and Cara who
raised James and Margaret's children as
their own after their deaths what's more
in the finale we get our first hints
that this custom of caring for The
Unwanted and orphaned may be something
of a family custom that took Roots
decades before the events of Yellowstone
following Elizabeth's miscarriage Jack
Dutton suggests that rather than have
their own children their future may see
them adopting children who need a home
as a way of expanding their family and
continuing the Dutton Legacy could this
mean that Kevin Costner's John Dutton is
the child of an adopted Dutton himself
this would certainly establish a
thematic link between the two series and
explain John's penchant for caring for
lost souls for now however that's a
question best left for another time
as the Beatles so fondly reminded
listeners in their hit All You Need Is
Love love is a powerful and
unpredictable Force throughout season 1
of 1923 every Hero has to put their
faith in this joyous feeling Jacob has
mentioned repeatedly how his love for
his wife Cara has kept him strong while
Jack's love for his wife Elizabeth has
seen him through the death of his father
even tiona is finding solace in her
Newfound love as she escapes a life of
torment and anguish however the lesson
may have been learned best by Spencer
Dutton The Prodigal Son of the
Yellowstone Ranch who Begins the series
estranged from the family and seeking
his fortune a world away Spencer never
felt like he ever needed anybody but
himself but when an adventure seeking
Maiden named Alexandra hitches her ride
to his he discovers the power of love
and all it could help him accomplish but
he also has to deal with the dark side
and the pain love can cause when it is
taken away from you separated from Alex
at the close of the finale Spencer's
desperate cries to his new wife prove
that no matter what anyone takes from
you love binds for forever
[Music]
foreign